one of the central themes of Fran
kafka's short story The Metamorphosis
def fanlong in German is what we call
alienation and when I say that this is a
theme I don't mean that Kafka himself is
singling it out or even using the term
instead this is something that we
looking at the story judging its effect
on us how we interpret it how how we
feel about it how we imagine this
character Gregor samama and what he's
going through and also his family it's
something that we can put our finger on
and say really this story is not just
about a guy who turns into a bug it's
about how
alienation works or at the very least
how it can be depicted in a particular
but in a certain sense also perhaps
universally case so this is a short
story that has received um
interpretation literary criticism from
just about every vantage point you could
think of ranging from you know
psychoanalytic to Marxist readings to
formalist readings and I'm not going to
try to address all of that instead what
I'm going to talk about here is how to
look at this story basically from an
existentialist perspective um when we're
using this term
alienation uh the German for that is
infron and we see this as something that
Hegel
uses and the young Marx also talks quite
a bit about this as well so it it does
have some resonances with that you know
existentialism um in some respect was a
reaction against Hegel and
hegelianism but it also in in many of
its represent resentatives Incorporated
that at least the philosophical
Representatives um kard is still a
dialectical philosopher n is reacting
against Hegel but also doing some kind
of hegelian stuff now Kafka himself is
not a philosopher he's a short story
writer he is a novelist he writes
letters um he does know some some
philosophy he's studied it and he's
interested in themes that are that are
coming out of philosophy but he's really
interested in depicting particular
individual people and the
entire I don't want to say world but
milu in which they're caught up in this
one as I remarked in the previous video
the milu is actually pretty small we're
talking about a setting that comprises
one apartment except for the very very
end of the story where they go out to
the countryside after Gregor has died um
the entire milu is one apartment
but you can imagine a world World um
that encompasses more that's just not on
the stage so to speak and that's an
important part of what we're calling
alienation here so we should spend a
little bit of time before we actually
start looking at specific examples and
modalities in thinking about what we
mean by alienation and like I remarked
um we're not trying to take this in a
very strict Marxist sense there are some
ways in which this overlaps with Marxist
classic analyses of
alienation um in his early works but you
know we're looking at some some other
aspects
so alienation and froing like I said in
in German literally means othering
becoming other so we want to ask ourself
um what does that mean uh becoming other
than what what is changing we're talking
about something that metaphysically we
would call a process of alteration or or
change
um like I put over here you know there's
an interplay of Truth and falsity
there's a sense in which in the process
of alienation or when one realizes that
one is alienated there's something false
and it's covering up what one feels to
be true or you know
correspondingly um if alienation really
is the fundamental Human Condition we go
from a false consciousness of thinking
that everything is a okay and you know
matters are going along swimmingly as
they say to a true realization that no
things are actually quite bad and
they're probably not going to get better
but we want to ask
ourselves
um alienation in what
sense what do we mean by becoming other
other than what other than myself other
than my social face or role other than
the person that I used to be other than
what I am on
paper all these things are important uh
respects we want to think about how
determinately a person becomes other in
this case you know we have we have sort
of something to hang it on namely that
Gregor Samson becomes a giant
bug but what does that really mean what
is the significance of that in human
terms you know when we're thinking about
this story if we want to say that it has
any meaning to us other than as a you
know kind of cool Fable we want to know
what does it have to say to us about our
own condition that's why this is a
classic
existentialist uh short
story so I've listed a number of
different becomings or being or losing
here this does not exhaust the
possibilities of understanding what
alienation means but I think these are
some good anchor points that give you a
strong sense of for Kafka at least
what's going on in this particular story
not everything that I'm saying here
would apply necessarily to um the trial
or his letter to his father or some of
the other the Judgment some of the other
works that he writes but I think that
quite a bit does and these are things
that that you see coming up over and
over
again so in a very very broad sense when
we talk about
alienation one conception that people
have when they use this term is becoming
isolated becoming separate becoming
antagonistic you know a Harmony being
disrupted um the processes of alienation
is for for example Marx depicts them uh
as
capitalism uh penetrates into
Institution s like the guild the
family um the the parish um people are
set in opposition to each other who were
not opposed before and we can include
along with that you know
marginalization when somebody is
deprived of a voice when somebody is
being pushed to the side and and what
they say no longer matters some people
are unable even to say the word I or me
about themselves as uh not Kafka remarks
but
Baken actually remarks in in one of his
um
analyses so that's one important sense
another important sense and this is
really Central in this
story being changed in one's social
roles the expectations that other people
have of one how one sees oneself as well
in terms of those roles and the
relations that one has with other people
some of these are are um you know very
intimate very clearly defined um father
to son brother to sister but even those
have some you know they have an
experiential content to them there's a
whole history there before Gregor's
transformation that we get glimpses of
uh in his relationship for example with
his sister but um there's also you know
some clearly DeMar ated ways of relating
that go beyond just that particular guy
and girl to brother sister you know as a
whole or father son as a whole or
provider to um those who are being taken
care of you know Gregor and his family
at first so being alienated means some
sort of change or transformation in
these and it doesn't necessarily have to
be a
change where
things actually do in fact change it
could just be a realization of One's Own
condition you know
um for example the debtor to creditor
relationship um it's very easy and this
is a contemporary example it's very easy
for college students to become debtors
because we not only give them student
loans um we also allow credit card
companies to pitch directly to them well
they're probably some of the most
vulnerable
um prospects for for that sort
of um that sort of Aristotle would
probably call it people catching so in
Plato um that sort of almost predatory
uh
exploitation and you know you you get
into debt and you don't really realize
what the debt is going to mean what the
relationship of debtor to creditor is
until down the line and and you start to
see how it's interfering with your
capacity to say buy something else on
credit or your ability to go out with
your friends uh because you know you're
in debt you can't run your credit cards
up any further or your ability to do
other things um there's not a change in
condition there there's a change in
awareness of condition and that can be
alienating as well um realizing that the
the person who you were in a
relationship with who you thought you
were in love with you're not actually in
love with you actually just desired them
and now you've made some commitments and
you're trying to figure out what the
hell am I going to do with those that
would be alienating as would be the
reverse of finding out that they never
really loved you in the first place they
really just liked you for whatever your
abilities to play guitar your
encyclopediacc me uh memory of of this
sort of thing the fact that you had
transportation to parties for them who
know who knows you know it any case
that's that's uh an important aspect a
whole range of ways in which one can be
alienated um another thing that comes up
in this
story becoming other to one's own
self Gregor is not only alienated
from his
work and
family as well as other other people who
are involved here in the process he
becomes alien to himself and there's a
few points where he kind of reflects
upon this and he he says not in these
exact words but something along these
lines what is actually happening to me
what do I want to hold on to um very
often these sorts of things are are
gradual processes in this case something
sudden happens at the beginning and as
time goes on he starts to think about
well you know do I should I be a bug or
should I be a
man um at least to the degree that he
can be being cut off from one's own
activities or
products here I'm thinking specifically
about Marx's analysis about alienated
labor where in the past I if I made
something with handiwork I could see
something of myself in the thing that I
made it bore a distinctive stamp and
Marx's um Marx's analysis was saying
that within industrial uh production and
capitalism where I'm just producing for
for its market value essentially what it
can be exchanged for its exchange value
as it's called
um I am cut off from the thing that I I
invest my labor in so you know think
about restaurant work for for a minute
now a
chef or you know even a s Chef or
somebody who's just at a station can say
yeah that's that's me out there that's
that's my product that you're you're
biting into that you're
appreciating but you know it's it's a
little bit less like that for a bus boy
for a
dishwasher um even you know think about
what what is a server doing I suppose at
the end of the night you know somebody
writes on it had a great experience um
so glad that you were in the front of
the house there's a sense in which yeah
I I did that that's that's me that's my
product um but for so many of us we're
cut off from what it is that we we make
what it is that we
produce um we may not even
be we may not even ever see the end
users of them and see whether they like
it or they don't like it appreciate it
now that's a that's a very economic
analysis and here I actually want to add
another term to this projects I think a
great example of this is Gregor having
the project before he turns into a bug
of sending his sister to the
conservatory to study music and saying
that you know he had plans he'd been
saving money he was going to announce it
to his family and not broke not not bear
any opposition uh to to the plans to
send his sister off and once he turns
into a bog there's a little bit of him
trying to you know figure out how am I
going to get to work you know maybe I
can make this this uh somehow you know
not turn into a complete catastrophe but
very quickly he realizes that no he's
going to be stuck in the apartment and
now the things that were his projects
the things that he had sort of invested
imaginatively and effectively with with
hopes
dreams um and
effort and labor they come to not they
they are not what he is anymore they are
other than than him um
finally and this is a very important one
for this losing one's own lived
body losing one's voice losing one's
face um does one thereby lose one's
identity or does one lose part of one's
identity this is a big important
question for this story and it's pure
contingency so you know one of the sort
of fast forwarding ahead one of the
things that the story is is suggesting
to us is you know you think you know who
you are you think that you can look in
the mirror and have a good sense of what
your body looks like but it's not going
to be the same two years from now 20
years from now it could be different
tomorrow you don't have to turn into a
bug you could get hit by the bus and
become paralyzed and totally dependent
on other people you could lose your your
face you could lose your voice you could
lose the things that you think are you
they are contingent they can be stripped
from you you can be transformed into
something different from somebody who's
fashionable and thin you can be
transformed into somebody who's
old-fashioned and fat um from somebody
who's in Stellar shape you can be
transformed into somebody who's out of
shape um the the the Converse is true as
well well except for you know young to
to old right you can't get any younger
because time doesn't work that way but
that's a form of alienation as well so
we're going to look at each of these
we're going to focus
particularly on three main forms of
alienation that are taking place what we
might call the economic or social type
of alienation that's going on that's
depicted in this uh alienation within
the family the the structure that that
Gregor is a part of at the beginning and
then has to essentially recede from
although at the same time he's still a
member of the family and then Gregor's
own alienation from himself particularly
in terms of his body and in terms of
becoming other to his own Consciousness
how should we think about economic and
social alienation in the metamorphosis
what does the story reveal to us is this
really important is this at the center
of the story or is it just peripheral
concerns and we should really be looking
much more closely at Gregor's body or
his his own feelings after all most of
the economic activity uh the whole of
society takes place outside of the walls
of the apartment um maybe Kafka is
suggesting to us that only the F family
Dynamics matter I don't think that's
really the case I think that he is
situating the family very very uh
cleverly by by use of narrative by use
of sort of interior discourse
particularly on the side of Gregor and
his descriptions of of the family to say
that say something about modern uh
society and um the situations that we
can be caught
within if you think about the social
status of this
family um like many of kafka's
characters many of because or
organizations or groups it's got a kind
of equivocal status on the one hand you
could say that they're just good
Bourgeois people you know look at them
they have a household they own an
apartment they have
servants um the father you know is
retired he can sit there in the morning
and linger over breakfast because he's
got this good hardworking son who's out
there making money um you know slowly
moving up in the
organization and you know contributing
to the the good of the household the
mother really doesn't have to to work
too much you know she does a little bit
of domestic things here and there but
really manages the household sister's a
young kid she can think about greater
you know greater prospects perhaps even
going to the
conservatory advancing out of their
their situation that's where they are at
the beginning and that's where Gregory
actually thinks that they're going to be
for a little while he thinks that this
is just going to be a small
setback
um but as The Story Goes On we find out
that even the the present situation or
the beginning situation I've got a
little chart here this is sort of a a
charting out or a schematization of the
beginning situation this is where they
they end
up we realize that things are a lot
shakier than at first they they appear
that things are more insecure the only
thing that's actually keeping them
secure is the continuous efforts on this
at this point in time on Gregor's part
to do things that he finds uh
irritating even to a certain extent uh
demeaning he's got to give up some of
his dignity day in day out in the
situation the work situation that he's
in so here's the the
backstory the the father used to have a
business which again would put them in
the
Bourgeois um the the people who get to
call their own shots to some degree not
you know the OT bourjois the high uh the
high Bourgeois literally the upper class
but instead the the people that are able
to make a living and get to choose how
they're going to to do it you have to
cater to customers of course and clients
but it's it's your business and the
father's business failed it went
bankrupt as a matter of fact the firm
that Gregor currently works for holds
the father's
debts and Gregor still has several years
to go before he can pay off those debts
being a commercial salesman we we learn
is not a job that Gregor actually
wanted he was in the office um he could
have just been a
clerk it's not even clear that he wants
to be in an office at all but he said
well if I'm going to be in the office I
got to make more money I've got to
advance my position so I'll become a
commercial traveler and what does that
mean means being a travel traveling
salesman of sorts going around with
samples trying to in you know interest
other people in the products of the The
Firm so it means you know putting up
with a lot of
hassles um eating strange food he he
mentions you know having to sleep on wet
mattresses um you know imagine a life
where you're living out of hotel after
hotel after hotel and not the nice
places either the budget places the ones
where things aren't necessarily done up
to Snuff all the time because you know
it's it's cheaper that way and he he's
the one who's outside of the household
he's traveling he writes letters to his
family which shows that he's he's
separated from his family quite often
well they get to enjoy the benefits of
it being in the flat in the
apartment um but they don't do an awful
lot of anything they they have a
household you know they have a cook they
have a a servant girl but they do have
to you know live within certain means
cuz Gregor is not you know rolling in
money at the same time the father it
turns out has been able to save some of
the Investments that they had and he's
he's slowly um economizing and adding to
them over time
now this is a situation in
which the the alienation produced by
modern economic life is is largely born
by
Gregor um it's not clear that anybody
else and the firm is particularly happy
the boss sits up on top of a big stool
and shouts orders down at people
the chief clerk comes to you know check
up on Gregor there's a doctor mentioned
who basically you know he's supposed to
be a sick Lea doctor but he he he always
gives people a clean bill of health so
that they they can't uh take a sick day
and there's lots of other you know
smaller clerks here and there you don't
get the idea that anybody's particularly
well adjusted or or happy in this so um
what happens Gregor finds out just how
precarious his position actually is in
the first part of the novel after he's
turned into a bug the chief clerk comes
to the
place and when Gregor is trying to
figure out how he's going to get himself
out of bed how he's going to get himself
off to the train how he is going to make
good on all these commitments that he
has the chief clerk starts threatening
him and saying you know what we're not
really sure that we want to keep you in
this office you know I thought maybe
you're bonding with some money that's
probably not an issue but your work you
know it's not really up to Snuff and
Gregor you know before has been thinking
my work is actually uh good and what
this goes to show you is just how
precarious one's not only economic but
social situation is every workplace is a
little microcosm of social
relations
and these all intersect with each other
the household is permeable to the
greater economy as a matter of fact you
know the Greek word Ionia that we get
economy from means household means what
goes on within the household we've
expanded it to mean the the whole of
economic the whole of commercial
manufacturing uh
Transportation uh marketing activities
in general um and he's caught up within
the web of that and he's not happy about
it now what
happens as the family situation has to
change because their main uh bread
earner is is gone now they end
up in this situation where there's kind
of a triangle of the father the mother
and the sister and they're all
working they they they do some other
things first they talk about having
these Investments that the father had
put aside but those are not enough for
them to live on for a very long time um
they sell off some of the valuables that
they have some of he calls them
ornaments we can think of necklaces or
Rings or earrings or brooches or things
like that they take in these three
Lodgers they economize by getting rid of
the servants who are doing you know the
the kind of work that that would you
know put them in a Bourgeois family and
they have just one person coming in that
is described as a charom who's there
basically to do the really rough work
taking out the crappiest you know
garbage um maybe mopping the floor or
something like that
um they're dependent on these Lodgers as
we find out as time goes on um they have
to please them they've taken other
people into their very own home
because their economic situation is
becoming more and more dire because
Gregor cannot contribute Gregor Now is
really just a
liability as as the story proceedes the
father the mother the sister they all
take jobs I've got arrows going off in
different directions because they
they're all working in different places
they're not all working for this firm
they're not all working in some other
place each of them goes on off to their
own little world of work comes home and
what are they able to do basically just
crash they're not really able to engage
with each other the way that they used
to in the household when when Gregor was
working and he was affording them a
certain uh not luxury but at least
Leisure it he describes the father as
coming home in his uniform and he's very
you know proud of his uniform because it
shows that he's a working man now um but
he complains he says so this is what my
life is and his uniform becomes dirty
and dingy why because he doesn't take it
off because he crashes in his in his
chair and has to be cajoled to go off to
bed pretty late and he's going to wake
up early and do it the next day and and
the story talks about each one of them
doing the sorts of things sort of
extending themselves spending their
energy spending their life Force making
other people either happy or satisfied
doing
things
um why do they have to do
this they feel that they're under some
kind of
curse you know one of the ways in which
they could save money and we we have
talked about this in the other video and
it talks very clearly about this in the
the text they could move to another
apartment and it's possible that they
could transport Breer all they'd have to
do is find a box put them in the box cut
some holes in it transport them don't
let anyone see cuz if they do let anyone
see then their social standing which is
precarious right now already totally you
know unpredictable what would happen who
knows people might be totally shocked um
and say you've got a Vermin living with
you you're disgusting we want nothing to
do with
you they feel like they can't get out of
the situation that they're in that some
sort of of catastrophic guilt has fallen
upon them and there's nothing they can
do about it other than keep on working
keep on
laboring so their you know their
situation is slowly descending slowly
getting worse if Gregor were to continue
living if you know the story had a
fourth and a fifth and a sixth part we
don't know what would happen they might
uh become totally
destitute maybe the the sister or the
mother well the mother's kind of old for
that maybe the sister would have to
become a
prostitute maybe the father would have
to do something else equally unsavory we
don't really
know all of this is a play of
alienation in which Gregor himself is
caught up at the
beginning and the burden of this
alienation shifts more and more to to
his family as time goes
on perhaps that's one reason why among
many why Gregor himself becomes isolated
from his own family as we move from the
relations between Gregor and his family
with the outside world the social the
economic Dimensions the concerns with
being part of you know a larger hole in
which one has to labor one has to buy
one has to sell one has has to expand um
instead of worrying about the they the
what will people think now we're getting
a little bit closer to the very heart of
things now we're we're within the
portions of the story that are actually
happening before our eyes not in the
memories of the characters not as
reported as what's going on outside the
apartment but within there their
apartment and we've got these four
people a little Nu
family
and what's going to happen with them
what does it have to do with with
alienation we got Gregor at the center
here because Gregor really is the
central character but what's going on is
Gregor is being alienated from the rest
of his family who sort of triangulate
and line up in some respects against him
by by the very end and see him as a
curse as a a burden that they have to
bear and then as something that they're
they're free of in in the end that their
lives are now uh improved they have open
Horizons they can start thinking and
feeling like things are going to get
better for them not for
Gregor so let's I've got all these
things laid out here let's talk about
these but before we do that let's think
about why it is that Gregor is so cut
off so isolated I mean there's a symbol
of that in that he's in his
room and the door is kept shut open at
certain times so long as they can rely
on him to stay over there get away from
us don't transgress into the clean part
of the apartment where the humans
are you know it's interesting if you
think about it's become kind of a meme
oh you know he thinks he's a human you
know we see a cat laying on a pillow
underneath a blanket and we take a
picture of it we say oh how cute it
thinks it's
people Gregor still thinks he's people
and they're rather ambivalent about
whether he is still people or not that's
one dimension of the alienation and
these are not just you know Jo blow on
the street who sees a big bugman coming
at him and doesn't really want to um you
know see him as a person because he's
got these prejudices that bugs are you
know not not the same thing as people
probably you know good prejudices
because our experience bears that out um
these are his family these are the
people who he has grown up with the
people who he saw change over time the
people with whom he has a kind of
intimacy so this is pretty dark and deep
Stu stuff here so let's look at the most
complicated relationship
first the one between him and his
sister prior to his
transformation Gregor is closest to his
sister and it makes good sense she's his
kid's sister he takes care of her you
notice that I have her as his caretaker
but PRI prior to that he's really taking
care of her he's not only taking care of
her by providing the money for the
family in general so they're able to eat
because of him they're able to have a
you know roof over their heads because
of him they're able to be well clothed
um he's actually saving to try to make
her her dreams come true to have her
talents realized he cares for her he
loves
her and in in her way she she does that
for him pretty reliably although you
know as time goes on more and more
cursor we would say um
um but what happens
so Gregor is transformed into a
bug and Greta kind of steps up the very
first thing that she does for him that's
you know showing us what her
relationship to him is is trying to
figure out what he can eat she starts
with milk because she knows that he
really enjoys milk and he can't eat that
so she tries bring out some you know
some other food and she does a
scientific experiment of sorts you know
bringing out good food what we would
consider good bringing out spoiled food
turns out that he likes a spoiled food
so she she feeds him that but already
she's starting to feel a kind of disgust
with him because you can you can tell
she picks up the food dish with a cloth
she doesn't want to touch it there
there's a contamination that would take
place if she were to allow her her
fingers her flesh to come into contact
with things that he has sullied or
besmeared
um she also sets herself up as the
expert on things Gregor related and so
she's the one who comes up with the plan
of you know taking his room she realizes
that he likes crawling all over the the
walls and the ceiling and she says let's
let's make it better for him um the
mother is not so so keen on that we'll
talk about why in a moment um the sister
is the one who comes to terms with
Gregor's
change in you know the first in second
part most um comfortably she's she's
able to say well it is Gregor but by the
end she is the one who actually voices
the the opinion when he comes out
because he loves her music he
appreciates what she's doing he wants to
show his his gratitude his you know the
fact that um these other people are not
enjoying the music but he likes it so
much
and in the third part this goes away
she's already started to you know become
sloppy and you know Hasty and getting
the the caretaking done um but she has
this speech where she says look we've
we've tried working with him we I don't
think this thing is him anymore I don't
think this is the Gregor who we knew
loved if it was it would have gotten out
of here and left us
alone
um he's not he's not that we we you know
we shouldn't see this as your son my my
brother so there's you know a complete
cutting off at that point so you can say
that Gregor becomes progressively more
and more alienated from his sister he's
trying to overcome that but part of what
he's handicapped by not just by by the
fact of being a big disgusting boss
is that he has no voice he has no way to
communicate with her other than by his
own behavior and so you know that's
restricted to things
like setting up a sheet so that she
doesn't have to see him when he comes in
or making sure that he's out of out of
uh her sight when she comes in and
notice what that
means to show that he's being
appreciative he has to create an absence
he has to endure a lack of of
relationship and you know he can't
guarantee that his his uh overtures will
be actually um properly interpreted
respected uh responded
to let's turn now to The Other Extreme
the
father so from the very
beginning of his
transformation the father uh once he
sees Gregor for what he is he's a man of
action he displays hostility towards
Gregor at one point Kafka says that
Gregor realized and I think it in the
second part of the third part that his
father's view on things was that Gregor
had to be dealt with in the harshest way
possible why because his father wants to
keep things very clear he views himself
as defending the family as defending the
household against this this bug who also
happens to be his son you could see him
in a certain respect although Kafka is
not saying this as engaging in a kind of
disciplinarian ship you know maintaining
boundaries um putting the foot down when
it when it has to be done and he you
know at some points he's he's like ready
to kill Gregor
um Gregor for his part attempts to
appease his father um very unsuccessful
in doing so um you know know Gregor is
not very good at crawling around the
room but he's he's trying to you know
he's trying to do the right thing which
is get himself out of the family living
room and the father you know throws
apples at him one of which wounds him
and and may actually be you know one of
the causes of his death
um what's going on there well you know
if you think about it the relationship
between these two guys is one that is
has been from the very start from with a
certain kind of
rivalry uh they you know they swap off
being the main bread earner the person
who's responsible for the household the
one who's the authority um Gregor sees
that once he's transformed and his
father has to you know re resume
responsibility he steps up he's a
different man than what Gregor
remembered him being this guy who just
you know sits around and reads the paper
and is you know kind of easy to deal
with um they swapp in off the position
of being the man of the
house and there can only be one in this
household the father allowed Gregor to
do
that in order to pay off the father's
debts which he incurred Gregor didn't
incur them um he tricked Gregor a bit
when he was doing that he wasn't
completely on you know above the board
with him telling him about the financial
situation they had money but his father
said no you need to go out there and
work anyway way and then when Gregor is
no longer able to work and he's become a
liability for the family he is to be
kept locked away and if he comes out
he's going to get get hurt he's going to
get squashed
perhaps
um now the mother situation is a little
bit
different she actually is the one who
holds out hope that Gregor is still in
there and he is going to come out of
this somehow there's no evidence of that
on the father's part and it seems like
the the the sister has come to terms
with the idea that no he's a bug now we
gotta you know take his furniture out
and the mother says look you know isn't
this kind of showing him so she's she's
actually saying you know this is a
significative thing that guy in there
can still can he can still feel he can
still interpret aren't we showing him
that we've given up on him ever becoming
human
again uh at the same time the mother's
rather hysterical each each um
each time that Gregor breaks out of of
his room she she goes into fits um she's
she's a rather weak character but
there's a really interesting scene at
the end of the second part
where she has to appeal to the father
not to kill
Gregor and it's depicted in a really odd
and interesting
way um you know this is this is an era
in which women wore a lot of clothes
actually men wore a lot of clothes too
and it talks about her clothes having
been loosened and some of them taken off
so she's placed in in a rather
sexualized situation and she is you know
sort of begging her her
husband his father for the son's life
not to kill him he she's interceding and
she's placing herself at the father's
disposal in in doing
so um now Gregor ends up being alienated
from all these people a good question
you could ask is alienation occurring
between them no as a matter of fact like
I said there's a kind of triangulation
they feel themselves to be kind of a
common front they're all in it together
but Gregor is not in it with them Gregor
is off in the room a gross
disturbing presence who they cannot
unburden themselves of um and they don't
see any any future so long as he is
alive
so Gregor ends up being quite alienated
from the family unit from The Matrix in
which he was raised was born at the same
time he's unable to get away from them
and that's really at the center of the
experience of alienation it's not just
that something has changed that
something is not the way it ought to be
that something is inauthentic that
something is hurtful it's that you can't
get away from it and you can't seem to
make it
better you can't transform it into
whatever would be not alienation
Redemption the old way in which things
were uh moving forward anything along
those
lines in looking now at Gregor's
alienation from his own self we're
really at the core of alienation as it's
occurring as it's depicted in this this
story and notice that Kafka never you
know lays stress on any of these things
and says hey I really want you to pay
attention to this he just reports he
just lays out the the story for us and
lets us draw our our own judgments
inferences conclusions about that um now
there's two ways I think that we can we
can look at this there's the actual
bodily
transformation and here you know do we
want to say that this is symbolic uh in
the sense that if we want to talk about
the significance of it obviously we're
not all bugs ourself or liable to be
turned into bugs but there's ways in
which we can become alienated from our
own body our own form that happened to
to us in our own experience or that
other people have to
endure uh or do we want to place the
emphasis specifically on what it is that
Gregor himself is enduring literally in
in this story I think that it's
important to begin with looking at his
bodily transformation and how
Kafka depicts it to us he's he's being
you know imaginative he's trying to say
what would it actually be like to be in
that sort of position but he's also
trying to be as sort of literal as
possible as dry as detailed there's very
little sentimentality
there so you know the very first thing
that Gregor notices is that he's got
these tiny little legs as opposed to his
own human
appendages he's got you know bugs legs
and bugs legs can be quite powerful
pound for pound right but if you don't
know what to do with them they just kind
of wave and and flutter and it takes him
a long time before he can actually get
control over them they respond
autonomically you might say uh Beyond
his own conscious control and and they
bother him because they're just waving
around wildly he's lost control over his
own not just over his own body but of
the part of his body that gets things
done that is responsive to our own
willing our desires our our projects our
plans
he's unable to carry out Locomotion in
the way that he would like to he also
can't grip things you notice that his
legs are useless for things like turning
a door knob um he's also got this heavy
carrus and it makes it difficult for him
to get out of bed at first um he has to
crawl around and he's he's got to you
know maneuver him himself uh in a way
very different than than a mammal would
be doing you know he has an exoskeleton
now he has a certain bulk that he has to
shift around uh there's several points
where he he leaves the apartment and
then or he leaves the his room in the
apartment and he's trying to get back
into his room and and turning around is
a difficult operation for
him so he's he's lost agility we could
say he's lost the capacity to use his
body in ways that are meaningful to him
within the space that he
has he also has antenna and Kafka just
has one line about that where he he says
um he began to actually begin to
appreciate what his antenna could do and
what do antenna do for bugs they're U
the the sites the organs of of other
reception of taking in other other
things kka doesn't actually tell us
anything about that he he's not doesn't
seem to be very interested in
that along with this change into the
body of
an insect goes changes in
taste we we've you know already talked
several times about the fact that now he
prefers rotten food he doesn't seem to
be bothered about you know living in
dust and his own filth that that doesn't
seem to uh have any sort of impact
positive or negative on him um the
things that he did like before at least
as far as eating goes He no longer
enjoys
um he does still enjoy music and and
there is a a reflection on his own part
am I such an animal that you know I'm
drawn to my sister's playing uh because
I'm just an animal now at that point
obviously if you can ask if he's just an
animal he's no long he's not just an
animal um but that's not really a change
in in aesthetic taste um but he does
have you know a change in physical taste
he has a change in interest he likes
running around on the ceiling you know
he he enjoys that um that's how he
spends his
time previously he would do things like
hang out with his family that's not an
option for him anymore um and he can
spend hours just roaming around early on
looking out the window um you know it's
it's not only people who undergo a
massive transformation like that it can
be just life conditions um you know as
we grow older there are some things
where our tastes change uh we become
receptive to a lot of things you know
some of them are quite good I didn't
like beer when I was a kid I like beer a
lot now uh and part because I I
appreciate bitter things but our
interests also change as well and if we
become sick if we become
incapacitated we can adapt ourselves
quite often to what would seem to us in
the past to be tediously
boring um you know looking at a ceiling
and just studying the patterns in the
ceiling to many people that sounds like
you know it would drive you up a wall
it's literally like watching paint
dry but you know placed into the right
sort of situation that can become all
right for one now what does that mean
what does it mean for a person that
they're willing to eat things that they
would have considered disgusting before
and they don't like the things that were
good what does it mean that they no
longer appreciate activities that they
were involved in before and are very
interested in doing other things instead
does it mean they become a different
person does it mean that they're no
longer the me that was back there that
there's no continuity between them or is
there continuity between them and
there's a kind of disjunction or a kind
of conflict or tension between
that there's a third
aspect to his transformation into a bug
his his loss of his own body um and
first The Voice happens it happens early
on he's able to speak in a way that can
be understood in the very first few
exchanges but then you know quite soon
after that he's only able to make noises
he's not able to communicate with with
people anymore and after that point he
doesn't try anymore he doesn't try to
say anything he tries to communicate
only with gestures not with his
voice he's lost
that are we alienated from ourselves
when we no longer have the means of
expression that we're accustomed
to that's a good
question that's one of the terrifying
aspects you see this in horror movies
where you know a ghost comes along and
someone suddenly somebody's mouth
disappears imagine what that would be
like not just not being able to eat now
not being able to
speak of course he doesn't have any you
know recourse to writing or or anything
like that because he can't because of
his legs he can't handle those sorts of
things he also loses his vision to a
certain extent not completely but he you
know he's talked about being uh at the
window and looking outside the window
that's a connection to the outside world
and gradually the things that are clear
to him become more and more hazy he's
he's losing his sense of Loc a he's
losing uh his sense of being able to see
where he is in the
world now all of that would be quite
alienating this is an extreme
example um what about how he takes this
what about his concept or his experience
of himself I think this is stuff that we
can relate to a bit
easier obviously he can't work anymore
he thought thought of himself he
pictured himself as being the man of the
house being the one who you know would
take care of everybody else the one who
is stuck paying off his father's debts
but it seems to be okay with it it's the
right thing to do he's um you know he's
got this sense of being an
autonomous um
dedicated um diligent individual who who
does a good job who brings in good money
and already early on uh he's already
transformed in his body but he hasn't
quite lost his job yet the chief clerk
is suggesting to him that maybe these
things are not quite true that his
position at the firm is not as strong as
he thinks it is that he's not as good of
a worker as as he believes himself to be
and the chief clerk is doing this in in
hearing of his family so this is very
um upsetting to to Gregor and Gregor has
to come to terms with the fact that he
will never be able to work again in the
first half the first not half the first
section of it the first third he's
actually trying to figure out how am I
going to get myself out of this room and
on to the next train because I missed
the the first train that I was supposed
to be on how am I going to get myself to
work so I can actually hold down my job
that is is removed from him as a
possibility so for a person who's come
to think of themselves very much in
terms of of their profession of of their
their work of their career and this goes
for many of us it can be very staggering
to lose that it can feel like losing who
one is losing one's very own identity
even moving from from firm to firm or
from you know institution institution or
changing do job description can be quite
a a shock shock to the system for for
many
people so there's that there's also his
family like we said he becomes alienated
from his family and he is still able to
some degree to interpret himself what he
is through their eyes and so he's got a
kind of fragmented self he he realizes
that he can't effectively communicate
with them they can still effectively
communicate with him and about him
uh but their interest seems to be mainly
in the father's case keeping him in that
room and attacking him when he's not in
the mother's case crying and and going
into hysterics when she sees him and
sort of expressing hopes from a distance
and in the sister's case um you know
being very interested at first and then
sort of you know losing interest over a
while and of course you know with the
choman getting poked at you know with a
broom and being called a dung beetle
so
you know who is he really he's no longer
this ties in with the work he's no
longer Gregor the brother the son who is
earning a good living about whom they
can be proud instead he's Gregor the
horrible Family secret that has to be
kept locked away in that room lest
anybody see it except for of course you
know the cleaning lady somebody's got to
see your dirty
laundry
his desires how does he understand
himself in relation to his own desires
there are two really interesting
points where he's reflective about
what's going on I've already mentioned
one of them where he hears the music
this is in part three he's hearing the
music and he says what's going on with
me am I so so much of an animal that I'm
just moved like a Savage Beast to listen
to her her violin playing um and you
know we might write that off as was kind
of a
sentimentalism but more
telling is the occasion in part
two where the sister proposes that they
take some of the furniture out of the
room and so that Gregor can crawl around
on the ceiling and and on the walls
unimpeded you know essentially making it
into a a more open space for him and he
thinks yeah that's great I love that you
know she's so she's so nice she's taking
care of me and then the mother says
aren't we
showing that we're we're giving up on
him by doing this and then Gregor
thinks oh
yeah I'm not a
bug I'm I'm me what's wrong with me that
I thought that was a good idea let's not
do that and then of course he tries to
communicate that in a way that scares
the mother by by crawling on to
something a portrait of a woman and just
hanging on to it and and not allowing
them to to come near it
but he's shocked by his own changed
desires he realizes that he's not who he
thinks that he is or at least there's a
part of him that's very different than
than what he thought himself to
be I think that another important
dimension of his alienation from himself
is his sense of time at the beginning he
is caught up within the time of the work
world there's a a kind of routine to his
his life um you know go off to work go
you know here and there and do the
commercial traveler thing rise early um
go to bed fairly early so he can get up
the next day and do it all over
again there's a pressing of time when he
realizes that he slept through the alarm
clock and he needs to catch the train in
the first
part and all of that disappears with
with his catastrophe with his with his
metamorphosis his transformation into
this this bug because now all he's got
is time and the days and weeks blur into
each other and time there is still some
continuity and that there's day and
night there's you know morning and
evening there's the work world that that
is his uh family is involved in but
there's no meaningful time for him
there's occasions where he comes out and
does things but he doesn't even seem to
reflect on those in in the course of the
story he doesn't seem to say you know I
I should I should think about how much
time has been spent on this and what's
going on he he no longer worries about
any of that in a way it's liberating but
in a way it's also a sign of just how
bad things have have gotten for him so
Gregor is in in really serious ways
alienated from his own self he is still
who he is but he's stuck in this bug's
body and the body is making its own
demands on him and changing him in the
process there's an interesting question
here about are we our our bodies or are
we something else or are we you know
fused with our bodies how do our bodies
matter to us how do the desires that
come with our bodies make us into who we
are but then there's also this this this
you might say category of reflectiveness
of the capacity to take stock of oneself
to be conscious of of who one one is to
have a concept or or experience of
oneself
and he experiences himself as something
other as he's still Gregor but he's also
not Gregor and there's a variety of
different ways in which this is being
registered as I bring this to a close
some very quick afterthoughts some
parting ideas to leave you with as we
think in terms of this theme of
alienation and the short story um Kafka
is is a writer Kafka like I've said
before is not um doing philosophy
although his work has philosophical
implications and deals with some
important philosophical
themes what's actually going on here are
we getting a depiction of
alienation Kafka doesn't say that I'm
I'm going to you know
sketch alienation as it takes place in
this one uh instance with a man who
becomes a beetle and his family and the
economy that he's caught in or anything
like that we're bringing we're bringing
that to it by way of interpretation and
like I've said before there's many uh
interpretations of this this short story
that are available in the secondary
literature I think we want to focus on a
few features of this writerly work to
think about our own
relationship to what's going on in
it so one thing is we know
more at least about some things than any
of the characters
do we're given glimpses into their
thought we're able to attain a
perspective uh by by sort of
leapfrogging through time that the
characters are not getting themselves
and that's part of the the process of uh
constructing a plot right plot doesn't
include every single thing that happened
it includes the things that are relevant
the things that create a picture the
things that show us character that show
us thought you know these are all
basically just things straight out of
Aristotle's Poetics um but we know more
than any of the characters we are able
to form sort of a composite picture of
that does that mean that were able to
see their
alienation in a way that they cannot
probably
but are we also to a certain extent
separated from the characters do they
possess a sort of
opacity to us that they retain it's a
good question to think about you
especially with with Gregor in his
metamorphosis where he just said that
he's not quite sure what to make of it
himself he he goes through you know a
learning process and by the time that
he's figured out what the hell is going
on he's dead uh and his family you know
did they learn anything in the process
not really about Gregor not really about
you know life they've learned something
about themselves in the process and the
prospects that they have and that they
now have a
future we're able to feel the situation
we're able to reflect on it in ways it's
able to have effects on us that the are
not there for the characters it's not
like you know they're expressing horror
and we're just you know mimetically you
know reproducing it in ourselves are
participating in theirs the way we do
with some some books where we identify
with the
characters we do you know if we want to
we do kind of identify with Gregor we
might even identify with some of the
other characters how sad it is for his
mother for his sister even for his
father but there's something Beyond
identification
here and again that's something that
Kafka as an artist makes possible for
us one of the things we want to ask
ourselves if we want to think about
implications is this just supposed to be
a
story about a guy who turns into a
bug maybe then it it's not really that
important maybe it's not something that
we should assign to undergraduates or
high school students or middle school
students that's when I read it to read
and and think about and talk about the
great
themes it's just some story about a guy
who turns into a bug how often does that
happen it's not going to give us any
usable details and it might tell kind of
a you know cool thing but it's not like
he goes and fights crime or you becomes
you know an Explorer or tells us about
the insect world it's actually just
stays at home in an
apartment so if it's just a story it's
probably not worth
ring or is it a
fable is there a moral to this story
notice I also ask is it a parable this
is a term that Kafka himself thought a
lot about and liked to use um I'm going
to talk in other videos about kafka's
Parables and his own conception of of
parable what's the difference between a
fable and a parable with a fable there's
a moral to it you know um the the dog
loses the bone cuz he's looking and
barking at the dog his reflection in
there and the bone falls in the water so
what's the moral you know don't don't
bark at at people uh when when you've
already got something in your mouth no
it's not that it's it's actually don't
be jealous of what other people have
because then you'll probably lose what
you've got with a
parable it's not so
straightforward can be read multiple
ways you have to sit and think about it
maybe the different characters are are
only symbolic maybe they mean something
more these are the sorts of things that
you have to meditate upon where I want
to leave you in thinking about this has
to do with alienation and and these
thoughts here is this about our own
alienation does Gregor's alienation does
the alienation that these characters
experience in his family is the
alienation that's depicted here of
modern
Bourgeois uh capitalist Society bear
upon us or does it you know is it just
telling us things we already knew um is
it telling us anything novel is it
revealing any New Perspectives to us
that's something that we want to keep in
mind mind when it comes to this and we
also want to think about does kafka's
Artistry allow us to see alienation
going on although he never uses that
term does it allow us to see alienation
in a way that mere reporting or
philosophical you know writing with with
throwing in some examples to Pepper it
uh and make it more specific wouldn't be
able to do is what Kafka is doing here
depicting alienation in ways different
than say we might see in dovi or in sart
or in Simone deir or Gabriel
Marcel these are all important things to
think about and so I just leave you with
them as sort of parting shots